on reçoit Denis Dousset porte-parole de
multiples hypothèque bonsoir Monsieur
Doucet bonsoir alors c'est une situation
particulière on voit que le nombre de
transactions diminue les prix aussi qui
ont reculé depuis le sommet d'ailleurs
la SCHL s'attend à un recul encore des
prix d'ici la fin de l'année des jardins
parle de 17 % entre le sommet et la fin
2023 au Québec est-ce que vous diriez au
nouveau acheteurs ils ont un peu de
temps devant eux d'attendre pas
nécessairement l'achat d'une maison
c'est comme certains essayeraient
d'acheter à la Bourse puis dire je vais
attendre que les actions baissent pour
les acheter jouer à ce jeu là les
spécialistes vont nous dire c'est très
très risqué moi je pense quand les gens
s'engagent dans un projet pour s'acheter
une maison on doit vérifier notre budget
vérifier notre capacité et peut-être
sélectionner une maison qui sera à la
compatible avec nos moyens justement
cette capacité d'emprunt à quel point
est-ce que les prix autorisations qu'on
peut obtenir les institutions
financières tiennent compte de
l'augmentation du coût de la vie des
autres dépenses qu'on peut avoir est-ce
qu'on doit se fier à ça aller jusque là
la priorisation c'est un calcul sans
tenir compte de ni de l'inflation ni des
autres facteurs uniquement pour dire aux
gens regardez au-delà de ce montant là
vous ne pourrez pas emprunter donc c'est
la limite limite mais avant ça c'était
un des indicateurs mais les gens doivent
faire un exercice budgétaire se faire
conseiller soit par un courtier
hypothécaire par un conseiller en
finance personnel mais essayer de voir
avec leur budget et ce qui peut
anticiper comme frais supplémentaire ou
puis là c'est pas juste à court terme
parce malheureusement les gens gardent
souvent dans un horizon de 6 mois ou un
an mais ce que j'ai l'impression de
l'intention d'avoir un enfant l'année
prochaine si oui les coûts ça peut
regénérer et à ce moment-là on peut
établir un paiement avec lequel les gens
pourront vivre correctement et ce
paiement là correspondra à un certain
montant mais effectivement plus les
augmente si on prend le dernier six mois
la capacité d'emprunt à diminuer de
15-20% pour les gens c'est ça la réalité
fait quelques marchés baisse c'est que
comme la capacité d'emprunt baisse ben
si les gens veulent vendre ils ont pas
autre choix que de baisser les prix
parce que sinon il y aura pas
d'acheteurs et la question que tout le
monde se pose fixe ou variable dans le
contexte actuel qu'est-ce que vous
privilégiez vous la question se pose
tout le temps le traditionnellement le
taux fixe pris une journée donnée et
toujours inférieure pratiquement
toujours inférieur sauf exception auto
fait de l'auto variable toujours
inférieur au taux fixe mais il reste que
il y a une possibilité de variation de
paiement et ce qu'on a comme information
actuellement que ce soit de la Banque du
Canada que ce soit de la fête aux
États-Unis ils ont l'intention de
continuer à augmenter les taux jusqu'à
ce que l'inflation soit contenue autour
de deux pour cent on est encore loin de
ça donc on peut s'attendre à
peut-être que l'économie que les gens
croient faire à court terme mais va se
résorber dans les prochains mois puis
peut-être que dans six mois il se
retrouveront avec un taux d'intérêt qui
est supérieur au taux fixe qui pourrait
avoir aujourd'hui donc aller vers le
taux fixe je comprends c'est peut-être
plus prudent dans le contexte actuel
surtout pour des premiers acheteurs
parce que souvent les premiers acheteurs
sont budgétairement un peu plus serrés
que quelqu'un qui est rendu sa 4e maison
évidemment puis c'est peut-être pour
moins pour le premier terme puis par la
suite pourront réévaluer ça vaut la
peine ou pas à quel point est-ce que les
taux affichés par les institutions
financières tiennent compte des hausses
à venir de la Banque du Canada est-ce
qu'elles sont déjà intégrées en partie
de ce qui s'en vient la bourse anticipe
les taux des obligataires anticipent les
fluctuations faccales on voit par
exemple comme actuellement la bourse qui
diminue on peut s'attendre à ce que il y
a plusieurs investisseurs qui
s'attendent à des Rousses de taux c'est
à cause de ça que ça diminue mais les
banques eux ils vont avec les données
qu'ils ont au fur et à mesure que le
temps avance puis évidemment quand le
gouvernement augmente les taux mais pour
eux c'est des frais supplémentaires pour
le coup des fonds et ça signifie des
augmentations aussi sur leur taux autant
fixe que variable il y a des gens qui
avaient des paiements fixes un taux
variable donc il paie de moins en moins
de capital est-ce que c'est le temps de
revoir les paiements hypothécaires
faut aussi revoir moi je pensais c'est
du cas par cas on peut pas donner un
conseil de dire de transférer leur fixe
et sa presse il faut plus voir bon c'est
quoi les les conditions que vous avez
actuellement il reste combien de temps
au terme si vous convertissez c'est à
quel taux vous allez convertir puis là à
ce moment-là les gens peuvent prendre
une décision un peu plus éclairée moi je
pense que chacun doit voir les règles de
son contrat parce que c'est pas des
règles universelles étaient les règles
du taux variable chaque prêteur organise
ces modalités donc faut voir avec ce
chacune des modalités et la situation
des gens bon si ça augmente puis se
retrouvent avec un taux affiché au lieu
du Tour contractuel qu'on pourrait
peut-être négocier mais c'est peut-être
pas si avantageux que ça mais est-ce que
ça vaut la peine de magasiner on se le
fait toujours dire quand on achète une
maison pour la première fois
et oui mais ça ne devrait pas être la
première chose qu'on fait au départ
faudrait faire une réflexion déjà sur
quel terme j'ai besoin combien d'argent
quel genre de maison je vais
budgétairement quel montant de paiement
je peux me permettre à ça on se fait
préqualifier après à quoi ça correspond
et ensuite on pourra être un peu comme
quand on achète une auto avant de parler
de prix on va décider le modèle on va
décider de les options quand on sait
qu'est-ce qu'on veut là on peut se
promener puis magasiner le prix merci
beaucoup monsieur Doucet très
intéressant tout ça merci au revoir pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez-vous
sur la chaîne ici RDI